So Donald Trump had a complete authoritarian
tirade on Twitter yesterday as his leads in
a few states started to diminish.
And with those leads, the possible
path to 270 electoral votes started to narrow for
Donald Trump. Now, remember that this is all after
Donald Trump already declared victory at 2:00
a.m. early Wednesday morning. Quick reminder of
what that looked like. He already said he won.
So we won there. We lead by 76000 votes with
almost nothing left. And all of
a sudden everything just stopped.
This is a fraud on the American public.
This is an embarrassment to our country.
We were getting ready to win this election.
Frankly, we did win this election.
So our goal now is to ensure the integrity for the
good of this nation. This is a very big moment.
This is a major fraud in our nation. We
want the law to be used in a proper manner.
So we'll be going to the U.S. Supreme Court.
We want all voting to stop. We don't want
them to find any ballots at four o'clock in
the morning and add them to the list. OK.
It's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me, this a very sad moment
and we will win this. And as far as
I'm concerned, we already have one.
So I just want to thank you. Now, we warned
at the time about the Red Mirage scenario.
We talked about the Red Mirage scenario prior to
the election. And I warned you that because of the
mail in ballot volume that is expected and
the rules in some states like Pennsylvania,
where they cannot even start counting the
mail in ballots until the polls have closed,
we should be aware and be cautious that an
early Trump lead in some states may not endure.
And case in points, we saw Wisconsin shift from
a Trump lead to a Biden win. We saw Michigan
shift from a Trump lead to a Biden win, and
we're watching other states. As of this time,
Trump loses it and his tweets were so weaponized
in terms of spreading voter disinformation
about the election that most of them were flagged
by Twitter. Take a look at this. Trump saying,
quote, Last night, I was leading often solidly in
many key states, in almost all instances, Democrat
run and controlled. Then one by one, they started
to magically disappear as surprise ballot dumps
were counted. Very strange. And the pollsters got
it completely and historically wrong in Twitter,
warning some or all of the content in this tweet
is disputed and it might be misleading about an
election. Trump then tweeting in all caps. What is
this all about? About a post from Matt Walsh about
some supposed injustice in another tweet which
has since been deleted altogether. What the hell
is going on? We don't know. Trump then tweeting,
they are finding Biden votes all over the place
in Pennsylvania, Wisconsin and Michigan. So
bad for our country now by finding he means
counting legal votes as the process is supposed
to go, you receive votes. You look at who they
voted for and you credit them to the appropriate
candidate. Trump again tweeting, How come every
time they count mail in ballot dumps, they are
so devastating in their percentage in power of
destruction? Because we knew from day one that the
in-person votes would favor Trump in many states,
but the mail and votes would favor Joe Biden. You
could really see Trump crumbling with it. Each
tweet going on to say, quote, They are working
hard to make up a 500000 vote advantage
in Pennsylvania, disappear ASEP. Likewise,
Michigan and others. And Twitter again warning
this may be misleading about an election. Trump
tweeting, We are winning Pennsylvania big,
but the secretary of state just announced there
are millions of ballots left uncounted left to
be counted, which, of course, just means a lot
of people voted. And you've got to count those
votes. And then Trump tweeting. And this may be
the sort of like peak insanity. Trump saying,
We have claimed four electoral vote purposes,
the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania, the state
of Georgia and the state of North Carolina, each
one of which has a big Trump lead. Additionally,
we hereby claim the state of Michigan, if, in
fact, there was a large number of secretly dumped
ballots, as has been widely reported, Trump
claiming states that at the time he hadn't won.
And moments later, Michigan was actually called
for Joe Biden. Trump authoritarian nightmare
crumbling before our very eyes, even got
some messages from some conservative friends
in the southeast of the United States
who said Trump seems to be going crazy,
like I'm for low taxes and I don't like business
regulation. But Trump seems to have lost his mind.
And a bunch of people from the Southeast who
didn't even vote at all, interestingly enough,
wrote to me saying that we will see what
Trump's mental health looks like later today.